[Music]  earlier this week a man in Tennessee was  arrested for attempting to have sex with  an ATM yes people the audience actually  said what put up that news story again  I'm not making this up a guy tried to  have sex with an ATM now obviously it's  a very strange story and it's very  humiliating but today they release the  security footage of the incident yes I'm  sorry it's my job to tell you what's  going on and after watching the footage  closely I'm not sure that guy was  entirely to blame stop this this is  harassment  [Applause]  [Music]  that was way more romantic than I  thought okay I want to know where that  Bank is they've got my business